- [Mark] All right, Leanna.
Leanna, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- Montana
- [Mark] What city?
- In Missoula area.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood,
you grew up with both your parents?
- [Leanna] No, I was
actually abused until...
and I lived with my mom and dad,
for a little bit on and
off, and foster care
and then about seven
I was put into permanent foster care,
for three years, I lived
next to a guy who finally
became the governor of Montana
and then moved to
Missoula to a foster home,
till I was 20 at the age of 10 and a half.
- [Mark] So you left your
biological parents at what age?
- Officially about five or six,
that I finally couldn't
live with them anymore.
- [Mark] What was going
on that they lost you?
- My dad was abusive
and my mom was in and out
of the BHU Mental Hospital,
from the abuse.
- [Mark] Oh, he was
abusing your mom as well?
- Mmhmm, and my sister
- [Mark] And your sister.
How was your childhood in general?
- It was rough.
- [Mark] You were bounced around?
- I couldn't be who I was inside,
being trans in Montana,
would have probably gotten me killed
and I just didn't really
have a happy childhood.
- [Mark] You left home at what age?
- 19, I left the foster family,
actually, I said 20 but it was 19,
I tried working on and off up until 2006,
when I finally got my social security,
couldn't really hold a job that much,
because of my mental illness,
I was homeless quite a bit.
I actually got into a
really good apartment,
before I came here and gave
that up for my transition.
- [Mark] So you made the
transition from male to--
- Female.
- [Mark] At what age?
- I was 40 and a half
years old when I came out.
- [Mark] Oh, and how old are you now?
- 44.
- [Mark] Okay,
so this is fairly recent?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you lived all
your life mostly as a man,
kind of in hiding?
- In hiding, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] In Montana you have to, right?
- [Mark] They don't accept that, right?
- When I was in high school,
- [Mark] Especially when you were young--
- There was a famous case in Wyoming,
where a gay guy or gay kid got killed.
- [Mark] Yeah, I remember that.
- And so, I couldn't, I
knew I couldn't come out,
I struggled with it even
when I came out in 2016,
because it's still not
tolerated much, sir.
I made the choice to
start trying to be happy,
no matter what everybody else thinks.
- [Mark] At what point did you come to LA?
- I came here back in,
two years ago, in
February or March of 2019.
I wasn't expecting quite so
much hate, being an LGBT state.
I came here because it's one of the States
that does many mighty
for finishing transition
and I've been homeless ever since,
but I'm getting closer
to getting my house.
- [Mark] In terms of transition,
are you saying medically?
- Medically.
- [Mark] What have you done?
- I've been wanting to do surgeries,
but I can't have it until
I have my own place.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- There's a few different
surgeries that I'm wanting.
- [Mark] Sure, there are.
- Bottom surgery,
the Adam's apple and possibly voice.
- [Mark] Is that right?
- Right.
- [Mark] I know that a lot of
the ladies take hormones too.
- Yeah, I've been on those
since January 27th of 2017.
- [Mark] You're happier as a female?
- Yeah, I'm a lot happier.
- [Mark] That's great.
Where do you live now?
- I'm at a shelter off of Central Avenue.
- [Mark] So you're in Skid Row or?
- No, I'm almost,
I'm a few blocks past Vernon Avenue.
- [Mark] Oh, so you're not
really nearby Skid Row.
- No, I come here, hang out
at the Women's Center and
visit some of my friends but,
after
some hassle at Midnight Mission,
I've been trying to stay
out of Skid Row area.
- [Mark] You used to live here?
- I had a bad hate crime
happen on 5th and San Julian.
- [Mark] What happened?
- A week before Christmas,
a guy, because I was transgender hit me
with a metal folding chair several times,
broke my cane on me, hit me with fists,
and
I am still suffering a concussion from it.
- [Mark] So you used to
live on the street here?
- Yeah, I've had tons of hate crime.
I've been beat up several
times, almost burnt alive,
right outside of the Women's Center
where I slept on the street.
- [Mark] Somebody put you
on, set you're on fire?
- [Leanna] They doused
my sleeping bag with...
I woke up a few seconds later
with the zipper tampered with
and it's soaked with lighter fluid,
so many had chased him off.
- [Mark] Oh my God,
that's horrible.
- [Leanna] That was like
September 2nd, of 2019.
- [Mark] Wow.
So you're in a shelter right
now, that you feel safer in?
- [Leanna] Yeah.
One of the most dangerous
parts of LA for trans,
is right in the Skid Row area.
- [Mark] I'm sure there's
lots of violent crime here--
- [Leanna] There's lots of resources
and that's where most of us come.
- [Mark] Do you have friends?
- [Leanna] I have a few friends
at the downtown Women's Center,
I just got out of a
relationship with my ex
and anytime I made friends, I
don't have that many because,
my ex made me cut ties with
anybody I made friends with.
- [Mark] What do you do for money now?
- I'm on Social Security Disability,
but it's just not enough
to live off really.
- [Mark] Are there any other
options for you to make money?
- With my physical disabilities
and stuff, it's hard.
There's a few things I can do,
I just haven't gotten into doing it.
- [Mark] What are your disabilities?
- I have a real bad knee,
bad ankles, bad balance
and a severe bad back,
I fractured it one time,
been in multiple accidents,
along with degenerative disc, bulging disc
and
narrowing of the spine.
- [Mark] And you also mentioned mental?
- Yes, I have bipolar one,
ADHD, manic depression
and the manic depression
is the worst of it,
it makes it hard to hold a job.
- [Mark] I'm sure.
What do you wish was different
about your childhood,
that may have made your life easier?
- I just wish that there was more love,
I wish it was like today
when trans are able to
come out to their parents
and live the life that they wanna live,
instead of being forced to live
as somebody don't feel they are.
- [Mark] What do you think
the most misunderstood part
of being transgender is?
You must get all kinds
of different reactions,
violent reactions.
- The most wrong thinking
being transgender is
that it's a mental problem.
Over in Europe, they
actually have studies,
that pre-hrt and everything else.
They used to only be
able to do it by optopsy
and they weren't sure
whether the hormones
change the brain or not,
but there's different
site areas of the brain.
A trans individual matches
perfectly for female like me,
would match perfectly for female
and trans males match a male,
especially in the gray and
white area of the brain,
for matter wise,
there's all sorts of studies done
like at Oxford and European
countries that have proven that.
I just wish that a lot of
this would get out more to,
show and also there's studies where,
they asked five-year-old kids questions,
about how they feel as a gender
and the trans individual answer exactly
the way a female would
answer the questions.
There's no right or wrong
way to answer the questions
and the trans man answer, a boy answers
the same way a boy would answer,
and that kind of shows that
it's more in the brain,
than it is anything else.
The most common misconception is,
that we're mentally ill
or that we're confused,
or we don't know what we are
and if it would get out there more
on the studies, the hate might lessen.
- [Mark] Yeah, that'd be nice, right?
Do you have any family that
you stay in touch with?
- My mom and my sister,
my sister by
Facebook and my mom by phone.
- [Mark] This is your stepmom?
- My biological.
- [Mark] Your biological mom?
- I have a relationship with her,
even though I was in foster care.
- [Mark] I see.
- And then I have a old foster mom,
the one that I lived next to
the ex governor of Montana,
that I stay in touch with too as well,
but they're all the way back in Montana.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Leanna, thank you so
much for talking to me.
Good luck with everything,
getting housing.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.